[Aplausos]
[Música]
cuando estaba en la secundaria yo me
sentía una niñera profesional pero
profesional yo
siempre vivía en una cuadra que estaba
llena de niños entonces todas las tardes
llegábamos después de la comida nos
hacíamos tarea y de pronto la cuadra se
llenaba niños chiquitos bebés niños un
poquito menores que yo pero como yo
siempre fui la mayor yo siempre tomé la
responsabilidad de cuidarlos y la verdad
es que me encantaba me fascinaba está
rodeada de niños y como sentir que los
guiaba o les enseñaba algunas cosas
gracias a esta amplia experiencia unas
vacaciones comencé a mi mamá de que me
llevara al día yo sabía que los niños
que estaban en el deeb habían sido
separados de sus familias por cualquier
razón y yo sentía que podía apoyarme en
la limpieza del lugar
educación de los niños en el juego yo
quería ser voluntaria así que convencí a
mi mamá pudimos salir pero como yo era
súper tímida me quedé en el carro y le
pedí que ella para pedir informes por mí
yo me sentía muy muy confiada y dije
claro que van a necesitar apoyo y claro
que me van a aceptar cuando regreso a mi
mami el carro y le pregunto qué pasó
cuando empiezo no me dice no en el
disney's no acepta en este tipo de
voluntariado porque los niños se suelen
encargar con las personas que están ahí
y tú nada más puedes estar ahí 23
semanas
la luli de 12-13 años no agarraba la
onda como porque no querían que yo
ayudara porque no querían que yo
conviviera con esos niños
años después entendí que para suerte de
esos niños él no me quiso como
voluntaria
si los niños necesitaban apoyo el lugar
necesitaba personal pero no necesitaban
lo que yo quería y podía darles ellos
necesitaban seguridad y constancia y yo
no podía ofrecerlo
todo eso que debía haber aprendido con
el día vuelve a tener relevancia cuando
años después el cáncer llegan a nuestra
familia y de nuevo como familia estamos
en un lugar vulnerable
pero en el cáncer y yo somos best
friends así tenemos una relación bien
bien unida
soy sobreviviente de cáncer pediátrico
soy hermana de una sobreviviente tengo
30 años conviviendo con personas
relacionadas con la enfermedad y 12 años
trabajando con y para los pacientes le
he dedicado mi licenciatura mi maestría
en mi tiempo al estudio de la sociedad
civil el sistema de salud y las
necesidades de los pacientes con cáncer
y si yo pudiera resumir les todo eso que
les acabo de decir en lo más importante
que he aprendido es a contemplar las
necesidades y la dignidad de las otras
personas se puede escuchar sencillo pero
llega a ser un reto
en nuestro país la mayoría de las
personas cuando queremos ayudar
solamente pasamos vamos a me ocurrió y
ayudo no nos tomamos un momentito no nos
tomamos un momentito para capacitar qué
es lo que necesita la otra persona
les voy a platicar cómo es la
experiencia de ser paciente
nosotros vamos a un lugar a un hospital
oa una clínica y le llamamos cuartos de
quimio ahí es donde recibimos nuestro
tratamiento en estos cuartos de quimio
sólo entramos pacientes acompañantes y
el personal de salud nadie más
pero qué pasa cuando llega a un externo
qué pasa cuando alguien quiere entregar
un donativo un apoyo tomar un vídeo pues
puede parecer algo muy
insignificante o algo que no pues no
puede causar ningún daño que puede tener
de malo es que me les platico que puede
tener mucho de malo todo depende de a
quién se está poniendo como prioridad
no se imaginan la cantidad de veces que
me han escrito para solicitar me visitas
al área de quimio o inclusive tours
como si fuera un lugar turístico como si
fuera un lugar abierto al público y
estas solicitudes van desde que quieren
entregar un regalito una cartita o dar
palabras de aliento hasta escuelas que
quieren llevar a salones enteros porque
ganaron un premio por que recabaron la
mayor cantidad de donativos o peor aún
escuelas que quieren llevar a salones
enteros para que los chicos vean de
niños en una situación desfavorable o
vulnerable y ellos agarren la onda y
sean un poquito más agradecidos con su
vida que puede tener de malo como ven
puede tener mucho de malo todo depende
de a quién les estamos poniendo como
prioridad y no lo digo yo
y no lo digo yo perdón en nuestro país
todo paciente de cualquier diagnóstico
tiene 10
entre los cuales se encuentra el derecho
a un trato digno por parte de todo el
personal que elabora en la institución
donde recibe su atención y el derecho a
la confidencialidad el cual nos dice que
toda información relacionada con su
persona y con su diagnóstico debe de
mantenerse en total confidencialidad
solo la paciente o el paciente puede
decidir si quiere compartir su
experiencia su historia y detalles de su
enfermedad nada más ellos nada más de
ellos porque son los que están viviendo
en la enfermedad no el voluntario no la
directora de la asociación no el
director del hospital solo pueden
decidir los y las pacientes
pero qué pasa cuando el paciente o la
persona en vulnerabilidad es un menor de
edad
la familia no puede compartir esa
experiencia la familia no puede tomar
una fotografía
pues déjenme les cuento que tristemente
los niños y las niñas son el sujeto
favorito favorito de las personas los
influencers las las instituciones las
asociaciones y las empresas para hacerse
promoción y tristemente buscan el
momento en el que el niño o la niña
tienen más sufrimiento más en común y
más incomodidad y más dolor ese es el
momento que capturan ese es el momento
que promueven así que si ustedes me
preguntan puedo como familiar tomarle
fotos y compartirlas no porque ellos
también tienen derechos y esos derechos
no desaparecen solo porque tienen un
diagnóstico
como pueden ver el estar en una
situación vulnerable de pronto nos deja
callados y yo como paciente con cáncer
en su momento me callé como hermana en
su momento me callé porque por temor a
represalias por vergüenza por no querer
parecer mal agradecida o majadera y
quien te defiende quien te defiende
cuando tú no puedes quien se toma un
momentito nada más para ver si está
siendo tratado con dignidad o
simplemente con respeto
es tristemente son pocas las personas
que se toman ese momento y es que es
complicado porque a veces cuando está la
buena intención y la empatía juntos como
que no sabes identificar si estás
lastimando a otra persona
no nada más esto sucede en el área de
quimioterapia o en los hospitales qué
pasa si ustedes quieren compartir una
noticia o un suceso que está pasando y
esperan fuera del hospital digamos en
una tienda
siempre y cuando se trate de una persona
en un lugar vulnerable o viviendo una
situación de vulnerabilidad debemos de
tomarnos un momento para ver si estamos
poniendo nuestras necesidades antes de
las necesidades de la otra persona
hace dos años mi esposo y yo teníamos
todo nuestro día planeado y vamos a ir
al paso ir a mcdonald's desayunar ahí ir
a walmart recoger unas cosas al frente
de la tienda y luego ya nos íbamos a ir
a otras otras tiendas pues era un sábado
como cualquiera así que llegamos a la
tienda tomamos nuestro desayuno de
manera habitual platicando y por alguna
extraña razón se nos ocurrió en vez de
pasar al frente de la tienda por nuestra
mercancía ya ven que la recogen al
frente dijimos vamos a pasear
y así tan loca como esa ocurrencia de
pasar del frente a movernos un poquito
así de la nada nuestra vida cambió y
nuestro sábado se convirtió en un sábado
cualquiera a un sábado memorable
en un sábado donde todo cambio y sin
saberlo nos estábamos convirtiendo en
víctimas de un tiroteo masivo
logramos salir y cuando creímos que ya
todo lo peor había pasado y nos
sentíamos a salvo nos dimos cuenta que
no era así no podíamos entender lo que
lo que habíamos vivido porque tuvimos
que correr porque habíamos escuchado
aquellos sonidos no podíamos aprender ni
agarrarle la onda a la experiencia
porque whatsapp redes sociales y
noticias estaban llenas de imágenes
crudas de videos explícitos de las
víctimas
hasta la fecha yo no entiendo con qué
objetivo grabas algo así y peor aún y lo
publicas en redes sociales y lo
compartes si tu objetivo era ayudar
porque no grabas el momento del ataque
porque no grabas al culpable y lo
compartes sólo con las autoridades ellos
dieron canales oficiales para
compartirlo porque lo haces de manera
pública
entiendo que a veces gane la necesidad
de acumular likes de ser relevantes por
unos minutitos de hacernos virales o de
parecer que estamos informados de cierto
tema pero tenemos que dar a la onda de
que también todas nuestras acciones
todas nuestras decisiones pueden llegar
a crear un impacto a largo plazo en la
vida de otras
si esas imágenes hasta la fecha son un
tema a tratar entre mi esposo y yo y
fueron un tema que tuvimos que estar
hablando constantemente en las terapias
con la psicóloga no me puedo imaginar el
daño que causaron en las familias de las
víctimas y ellos no se merecían eso y
hasta la fecha no se lo merecen porque
en cada aniversario esas son las
imágenes que vuelven a proyectar
necesitamos desaprender lo que nos han
enseñado de ayudar el ayudar si es lindo
si hay que hacerlo pero hay que tener en
consideración qué es lo que necesita la
persona que recibe esa ayuda si está
siendo apoyado ha ayudado o acompañado
con respeto
yo los invito a que tomemos la
recomendación de instituciones por
ejemplo de la unidad que nos dice que
pasemos de una situación que hagamos de
una situación violenta que queramos
compartir una situación que sí pueda ser
compartida sin dañar hacemos de una
fotografía como la de la de la derecha
que pusimos en mujer y dónde ponemos
todos los detalles del paciente el
paciente en la cama el paciente
sufriendo y mejor lo compartamos de una
manera creativa de una manera que no
daña la dignidad de nadie una manera
donde sigo compartiendo el mensaje pero
no lastimó a nadie una manera donde
puedo seguir mostrando a las personas a
las que ayudó pero protegiendo su
identidad protegiendo su privacidad y
protegiendo todos los detalles muy
íntimos de su diagnóstico
les aprendamos de verdades aprendamos
siempre consideremos las necesidades y
la dignidad de las otras personas
al final de cuentas el cáncer el dif
igual me me enseñaron lo mismo a veces
para ayudar nos hace falta empatía
amor interés no a veces solo hace falta
una sola cosa
hacerlo con dignidad
[Aplausos]